welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul aka mo hawkeye and i'm
gonna do whatever it takes until people
finally realize that's a really good
joke yeah now the first trailer for
hawkeye is now here and in this video
we're gonna be breaking down all the
easter eggs things you missed hidden
details and also how it compares to the
comics because of that there will be
heavy spoilers so if you don't want
anything ruined then i recommend that
you check out now make sure you aim for
that thumbs up button and hit it and it
turns out you get double points for
hitting the subscribe button so yeah go
go and do that as well now without the
way thank you for clicking this now
let's get into hawkeye
okay so the last full appearance of
hawkeye happened in avengers end game
when we found out that he'd been
operating under the name the ronin
during the five years between the blip
and the snap moving in the shadows as a
gangster killing vigilante he'd built up
quite a reputation and this will likely
be brought into the show due to the
kinds of villains that show up in the
source material the story will be
heavily based on the hawkeye comic run
from 2013 and in that we follow clint as
he trains up as proto-jk bishop who also
goes under the name hawkeye set to
release on november 24th the series will
follow the pair as they fight crime
across the marvel universe in what will
probably be the most grounded disney
plus show so far now the first thing i
want to talk about is florence bew who
will be reprising her role in the series
as yelena belova blackwidow ended with
val going to her and telling her that
clint was responsible for her sister's
death i think that in the series she
will obviously seek revenge and become
one of the major antagonists for it but
that by the end she will learn the truth
about what really happened and this will
make her switch sides potentially we
might even see her join the avengers in
this series and it is possible that
she'll take over the black widow mantle
much like how she did in the comics now
we open in the midst of december with
clint and his family having a chinese
meal and celebrating being back together
his daughter lyla of course opened the
start of avengers end game it's nice to
see them all happy once more as that's
what clint wanted more than anything i
think it's great how she says this is
the first christmas they've had together
in years as they were of course snapped
away for five or whereas he wasn't now
even though the trailer hasn't been out
long a lot of people have been asking
why his wife isn't there and i'm unsure
if they split up or not after she
learned about what happened in the five
years i hope not but it is a possibility
and that would add even more weight to
them not having christmas together in
the comic book run hawkeye actually gets
served divorce papers however during the
trailer he does answer the phone and say
hey babes so i'm guessing things are
still pretty good though this mission
might cause some issues now cut to what
i believe is broadway and we see a steve
rogers musical which appears later on in
the first look here there are several
characters from the avengers including
the chitauri hawkeye black widow thor
and loki bruce banner steve and what i
think is the hulk really nice bit of
meta commentary about the
commercialization of superheroes and how
they're pretty much in every aspect of
entertainment now this is also a nice
little callback to the first avenger as
steve of course start off by traveling
the country doing propaganda tours this
is so that people would buy war bonds
which is also what the comic character
was used for in the real world he
clearly takes them to the show and at
his hotel room catches kate bishop
masquerading as the ronin which is of
course his old identity hawkeye sends
his family off in order to go and look
for her and it's clear that the past has
caught up to him at this point now we
could at the marvel studios logo and see
that a flowing target has been
superimposed over the top of it creating
a ripple effect this is of course
hawkeye symbol but if we're reaching
which we always are it could be a ripple
effect that has been caused by his
actions during the snap yes i said it
was a reach now for the next part of the
video i want to talk about the comics
and the brief outline of what happens in
them so that you can see how the trailer
lines up with that series the first
major enemies that we need to talk about
are the tracksuit mafia who are led by a
gangster named ivan they say bro a lot
of bro and though they're not really
major threats in terms of danger they
pop up from time to time throughout the
run and attempt to kill clint in the
comics ivan wears a blue tracksuit
whilst the rest wear red and it could be
possible that the scroll we saw on
episode one of loki was imitating him
and that's why it was pulled from the
timeline either way they own the
building that hawkeye lives at and they
end up tripling the rent and ousting the
tenants clint takes matters into his own
hands takes them down and also ends up
having somewhat of an affair with a wife
of a member known as cherry clint two
takes ivan's dog who is initially called
arrow but after realizing how on the
nose it is he changes their name to
lucky at one point we even get a full
issue from their perspective and they do
some really creative stuff with it in
the series that i hope carries across to
the show lucky will be appearing in the
first season and whereas kate was
already established in the comics at
this point the series will be telling
her mcu origin now we also know that
vincent inofrio will be returning as
kingpin in the series this was first
reported all the way back in june and
he's a big character in the comic book
run as well when we last saw him he was
getting beaten badly by daredevil and he
agreed not to expose his identity as it
would ruin his reputation having lost
his empire to a blind man kingpin of
course controls through fear and whether
the daredevil show still remains canon
we won't know for a while but lots of
rumors and reports are stating that
charlie cox will return as daredevil in
spiderman no way home so it does look
like it will kind of all tie together
and i really hope that it's all
connected as yeah that series was really
really good and pretty much the reason i
signed up to netflix now in the book a
security tape leaks showing hawkeye
killing a dictator called dookie fen and
this is poised to be sold on the black
market of madrapura which we last saw in
falcon in the winter soldier hawkeye
goes out there in order to stop it
getting out and we find out that kingpin
is attempting to buy it turns out this
auction is being run by madame mask who
it's rumored will be played by vera
formiga kate bishop ends up disguising
herself as her and all hell breaks loose
as they try and get the tape before it
gets out now that's the bare bones of
the first omnibus but it looks like
similar to the other shows that have
come before it that there will be some
elements taken and put into it whilst
others just stay out that's something
that's true of all marvel shows but i
definitely recommend picking up that
graphic novel run if you want to know
ahead of time the kind of stuff to
expect now we watch as hawkeye goes loki
in order to track down kate who is now
in deep with the wrong kinds of people
taking on the mantle of the ronin she
has inherited hawkeye's enemies too and
it's nice to see a character getting
some villains that aren't just tony
stalks now i actually think that val
will try and recruit kate but that
she'll shut the idea down and this will
be the first inkling that the young
avengers will be formed she believes
she's the world's greatest archer but we
see that she needs some practice when
she completely destroys a clock tower
with an arrow that has a tennis ball on
it this idea of all kinds of arrows is
actually ripped directly from the comics
and in the car chase scene that happens
we see that they go through hawkeye
zamarda later on in the trailer the
scene plays out almost beat for beta how
it does in the source material
even down to the car which looks exactly
like how it did in the comics during
this moment the hawkeyes are fleeing the
tracksuit mafia with cherry and ends
with kate using a boomerang arrow to
take down the mafia member that is
taking them hostage you also see the
lead up to central station and this is
of course a very important location in
the mcu as it's where the avengers
assembled for the very first time cut at
the tracksuit mafia and we see them
downing their infamous red colours now
we do catch what i believe is ivan as
he's donning a slightly different color
to the rest of them and he also has the
same facial hair that he does in the
comics after kate shows up to save him
and slams in head first we get some
action shots including clint jumping out
of a window running through a restaurant
like nathan drake and james bond beeruf
amiga who like i said i think is madame
mask and lucky who seems to be missing
an eye lucky was actually shot and badly
damaged earlier in the comics and
hawkeye ended up taking him to the vets
which this moment could be hinting at we
also get what i believe is a historical
reenactment of a fight and what might be
the rockefeller christmas tree in new
york never been there before only seen
it in the movies and i think i might be
right but let me know if i'm wrong now
we then catch the car chase which as i
mentioned is taken directly from the
source material and you might notice
that the van says trust a bro and bro is
of course the catchphrase of the
tracksuit mafia we end with the pair
jumping off something and turning around
and hawkeye of course did this in the
first avengers movie and it was probably
one of his most iconic shots this
actually also pulls directly from the
first page of the comic itself and it
makes for the perfect way to end this
really fun trailer
now as for my thoughts on the teaser
this was pretty much the show that i was
the least hyped for this year however
saying that your boy is about to become
a shillionaire because i think it looks
great and it's brilliant that they've
managed to make a festive romp as the
show will be shown over christmas who
doesn't love christmas who doesn't love
bow puns absolutely everyone and i think
yeah it looks really really fun
christmas was actually a big part of the
graphic novel and though we only spent
one issue during the time period it was
such a cool setting with all the snow
drops and the people constantly moving
through the white the white panels that
really made the art look absolutely
fantastic i think this has also been
brought across to the show and is such a
good setting for everything to take
place graphic novel run is actually
really really good and it's so well put
together that i think it'll be a
brilliant series if they stick to that
it explores a lot of hawkeye's origins
which is something that we haven't
really seen in the mcu and also helps to
introduce kate as one of the young
avengers so far the mcu has clearly been
building towards them and in both one
division and fatwoods there were some
key characters that popped up to let us
know what's coming i really hope that we
explore what happened with hawkeye in
between the snap and blip as that's such
an interesting time that the mcu has
just kind of skipped over we haven't
really had anything that's shown us what
happened in those five years and i would
love to see the character rock that
hawkeye went on after losing his family
now i think that this will probably be
one of the most straightforward mcu
shows as is not really any mind bending
or reality warping elements in it but it
should still be something that's worth
checking out like i said the comic run
is really good and if they can recapture
that which it looks like they're going
to be doing then there's a lot to be
excited about falcon and the winter
soldier showed us that we could have a
really grounded show that was still so
well put together and with characters
like the kingpin returning and elena
belova seeking revenge there are a lot
of things in it that could really hit
the mark overall it left me quivering
and here's to the 24th of november
really bad puns now obviously i'd love
to hear your thoughts yet i would
absolutely love it
if you dropped them in the comments
below so make sure you do and as a thank
you you'll be entered into a prize store
on the 30th of september in which we're
giving away three copies of zack
snyder's dc trilogy all you have to do
to be on the chance of winning is like
the video make sure you subscribe
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the trailer
we pick the comments at random at the
end of the month and the winners of the
last one on screen right now say that to
you then message me on twitter
heavyspoilers if you want something else
to watch then make sure you check out
our breakdown of what if episode 5 which
will be linked on screen right now you'd
have to be brain dead to miss it so
definitely go give it a watch right
after this without the way thank you for
sending through the video i've been paul
you take care of yourself and i'll see
you next time peace
you